[Music]
sorry you've done some work with the
heterodox academy right
uh yes that's right i gave the keynote
at their last meeting for example
have you seen the rise of the campus
left do you see it as becoming more
extreme in the past few years and
can you give some examples of that if
you do see it as becoming more extreme
uh yeah i think i think it has although
as i said in my address
uh contra contra billy joel we did start
the fire
we didn't mean the baby boomers and
there were episodes of intolerance and
shutting down of uh free speech uh when
i was an undergraduate
a number of decades ago but i think
there is an increase in the number of
uh speakers who are disinfighted who are
uh shouted down with uh loud
um protests sometimes physical
alteration altercations
with a setting of fire alarms
and we also know just by surveys of the
political affiliation of professors
that they are um drifting rather sharply
to the left
in many humanities departments there are
more marxists than there are
people who identify as conservatives why
do you think that is
um some of it is because of an increase
in
social and residential segregation that
people with higher amounts of education
uh live with other people who are just
like them
and people particularly in on college
campuses or
in large cities and um people who are
more conservative
tend to be more in the uh suburbs
excerpts in rural areas
uh partly because academia has some
i think some pathologies in terms of uh
people hiring people like themselves and
so that once there was a
generation that got tenure in many
departments they
uh replicated themselves hired people
with the same
uh political outlook uh so those are a
couple of the reasons
there's a there's also a natural there's
a
i think a natural affinity among
intellectuals for more
liberal positions some of it justified
it was often
liberals and leftists who were at the uh
forefront of
social movements that achievements we
now
uh take for granted and that we now
enjoy such as
racial equality uh gender equality
and um uh gay rights so some degree of
liberal filters may be a good thing but
when it comes to
stifling disagreement
and debate then it can become
[Music]
pathological
you